Hey youtubers it’s charlie and recently
warner brothers announced dates for 9 mystery
dc movies coming after Batman vs Superman.
So this video is going to be a breakdown of
what those might be. About half of them are
pretty obvious choices like Superman and Batman
sequels, it’s when we start thinking about
the other 4 or 5 that things get interesting.
If you’re just finding me for the first
time I do marvel and dc videos every week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
So let’s start with the actual list of dates.
I’m just going to read these off. Batman
vs Superman just got moved forward to March
25, 2016. Warner Brothers decided that they
didn’t want to compete with Captain America
3. Those two movies were set to come out on
the same day. It was funny, when they made
the announcement. Marvel people were tweeting
Captain America panels from the comics showing
him being a badass standing his ground.
It’s all big movie studio business stuff,
the only reason I care is because we get to
see Batman vs Superman two months earlier,
which is great. So you guys should think of
Then we get into the mystery movies. Here’s
what they are:
August 5th 2016, June 23 2017, November 17
2017, March 23 2018, July 27 2018, April 5
2019, June 14 2019, April 3 2020, June 19
2020.
What are all those movies, that’s a giant
list and why didn’t they announce names?
The best theory I’ve seen is that Warner
Bros knew they were going to move Batman vs
Superman and bow to Marvel. In addition Marvel
announced 6 new untitled films the week before
comic con. So Warner Brothers just made the
announcement to save some face.
Both studios absolutely do not care what each
other does. The DC people at Warner Brothers
don’t care about Marvel and Marvel doesn’t
care about the DC Movies. But, the money people,
the CEOs and board members of those companies
care a lot.
So the people actually making these movies
usually have absolutely nothing to do with
these types of announcements. Somebody in
a board room says, we need to make X Billion
Dollars each year, so because these movies
make X dollars you need to release X number
each year.
It’s a financial thing. Which sounds kind
of silly and it is. But what are the movies
going to end up being. Back in June there
was a list that supposedly leaked from inside
Warner Brothers.
It was that list of movies including Shazam
and the Green Lantern Flash Crossover. People
were saying it was the list of movies Warner
Brothers was going to announce at Comic Con.
That didn’t end up going down, maybe because
they saw Marvel wasn’t going to announce
their mystery films, but whatever.
That leaked list went as such, Shazam, Sandman,
Justice League, Wonder Woman, Flash/Green
Lantern Team Up and Man of Steel 2. That’s
only 6 of the 9 but those are all movies that
have been in development. Here’s what’s
going on with all of them.
Shazam - The Rock has already said he was
developing a DC project with Warner Brothers
a long time ago. Like several years ago they
met about him being Shazam but the movie never
happened. But he’s still at the top of their
list. So think of it as a Rock Shazam movie.
Sandman - There’s a big history with this
movie. Back in December of 2013 it was reported
that David S Goyer, the guy who wrote the
first Man of Steel Movie was writing a script
for Joseph Gordon Levitt to direct. Their
version was the Neil Gaiman Sandman, not the
Wesley Dodds Sandman that was part of JSA.
Before they came along, James Manigold, the
guy who directed the last Wolverine movie,
was going to do it as a tv show on HBO. Imagine
what that would have been like. That was pre
Game of Thrones, pre True Blood. So I’m
not surprised HBO didn’t move forward with
it.
And in case you heard about the CW tv series,
that’s for Hourman, not Sandman. I know
the Flash hasn’t even started, but the CW
is also developing a Rex Tyler Hourman tv
show.
Justice League - We’ve actually heard a
bunch about this. Mostly that Zack Snyder
is going to direct and the writer from Batman
vs Superman Chris Terrio, is going to write
it too. So basically the same team that’s
doing Batman vs Superman is going to do Justice
League. No surprise there. It just means Warner
Brothers really likes the stuff Zack Snyder
has being doing with the movie so far.
Wonder Woman - This would be Gal Gadot’s
solo movie. This is really hard to predict
because they’ve been very secretive about
her role on Batman vs Superman. She wasn’t
in the teaser trailer at comic con and they
only showed her costume. Which was exactly
what earlier leaks had reported it to be.
There was some images from the set of her
getting out of a car, but so far we know almost
nothing about her character.
I will go on the record as saying I like Gal
Gadot, but I’m going to withhold comments
about her doing a solo wonder woman movie
until I see some footage of her in Batman
vs Superman.
The Flash Green Lantern Team up - This is
going to make some of you guys short circuit.
Mostly because there’s no way they’re
going to let Grant Gustin be in the movie
as the Flash.
Geoff Johns already went on record during
comic con as saying the TV Shows and the Movies
are separate universes and will continue to
be that way. At least until all the executives
at warner brothers get fired and new ones
come in that want a shared universe.
Everybody knows what went down with Ryan Reynolds
Green Lantern. I think we’d all rather see
him in a Deadpool movie anyway. But Barry
Allen and Hal Jordan are both from Central
City, so that’s probably why they’d want
to put those characters together in a movie.
The Man of Steel Sequel. Originally that was
what Batman vs Superman was going to be, until
they stuffed it so full of A List actors and
characters it mutated into a Justice League
Prequel.
So the next solo Superman movie will be
a completely separate thing.
Here’s my thoughts about that list. They’re
going to focus on the holy trinity fist. Superman,
Batman, Wonder Woman, Justice League. All
of those movies will come out first. What’s
happening with Justice League is they’re
basically rolling right into production after
Batman vs Superman wraps. All of the same
people cast and crew are making both films.
So if Batman vs Superman is successful, they’ll
want to release Justice League as soon as
possible just to maintain people’s attention
spans.
I totally think they’ll let Ben Affleck
write the next solo Batman film. He might
not have time to direct, but he’s a great
writer who is also a great director. So it
wouldn’t be crazy for them to let him do
both. It would just be hard to do for a film
that big. Directors on those movies basically
go without sleep for two years straight. Acting
on top of that would make it almost impossible
without a life model decoy.
What about the other mystery films? There
are still 3 we need to figure out.
Right now the best rumors are for Metal Men,
Suicide Squad and Justice League 2. Of all
those, Justice League 2 seems the most likely.
Sequels are always easier to get made than
unfamiliar characters.
As comic book fans, the Suicide Squad and
Metal Men are totally familiar, but think
about this as if you had never read a comic
book in your life. That’s who movie studios
think about, like the masses of people who
will have no idea who these characters are.
Suicide Squad I totally buy as like an Expendables
type movie. If you ever saw John Carpenter’s
Escape from New York or Escape from Los Angeles.
Snake Plissken gets dumped into an urban war
zone with a kill switch wired into his brain.
Amanda Waller did the same thing when Arrow
did their Suicide Squad episode last year.
It was really cool. Basically an expendables
100 million dollar version of that Arrow episode.
Just as an alternative to that Metal Men movie
I’d like to suggest a movie centered around
a Villain. How many of you guys want to see
a movie where someone like Darkseid or Sinestro
or Jason Todd or some other DC big bad. I
feel like that’s something that would be
a lot of fun, like there is demand for that
type of movie. But it’s something that hasn’t
been done a lot by DC or Marvel.
But now it’s your turn, let me know which
DC Movies you want them to do?
In related news, I am seeing Ninja Turtles
tonight. It’s going to be fun in a whole
different type of way than Guardians of the
Galaxy was. So you should all go see it. Just
remember it’s supposed to be a fun movie,
not an oscar winning movie. I’ll post my
review for that tomorrow morning.
You can click here to get it. I’ll add the
annotation as soon as I post it.
And click here for a breakdown of the Batman
vs Superman trailer at comic con.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!